you don't like the feet dude no I don't
I don't want to be a fetish like a foot
and I do love feet I [ __ ] with feet
that's what I'm talking about
you don't like feet nah bro oh get out
of here bro I like grabbing this throw
up right this guy wasn't no [ __ ] he
wants to know all these guys
in crisis and I've been like this since
I'm young I almost said a child
it makes sense for kids they're closer
to the feet you know what I mean I've
read a study about that people that
babies climb on the floor and then you
get inherently like uh attracted to feet
over your mom's feet bro that's wow
crazy bro
just suck it on toes bro he does he does
I've seen that shelter
like where's the milk
you know you're on there by the way what
winky feet every you are on there
without a doubt what does that mean Dave
somebody took a picture of you while you
were like on vacation and you put up on
Instagram your feet I guarantee your
feet are on yeah I'm cool with that yeah
but if you want to know what you're
right yeah
sorry you got nasty my left foot is
horrible my right foot not bad is to see
he's on the left telling you I knew he
was on that [ __ ]
I don't say hi ranking what do I got
what is he says
pretty good yeah those are old put up
current pictures of these foot let me
see these ganglers
my God that's not bad [ __ ] out of here
no they're not nice dude these aren't
you you know yourself you don't deserve
that score what are you doing there bro
what was that your black toe what was
that that's how his foot looks no I had
I was I'm an athlete
shoes
I ever got [ __ ] thing
was fire he's like I'm matching the
shirt in the sandals what's wrong with
that
what's wrong with that that's what
they're saying
yeah
what's your score well I don't know look
at my rating just yeah let me check my
ego yeah I'm surprised how high is six
that's pretty good you look like you got
hairy feet bro I'm now they're cleaning
4.99
King of New York
wow let's see let's see scroll down
please son you almost got a perfect
score and your boy on the boat even
looking fly on a [ __ ] boat with my
foot
cams out I don't really I'm not too many
feet here I need to see a clear picture
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you slide
I mean yeah these are real feet bro
these are actually nice all right good
for you let's move on moving on yo let's
move on I'm tired of this no leave that
picture up bro I actually desires all
right what else